disparaît effectivement le 27 mars
dernier
et il a déclaration faite par son mari
Michel pial intervient que le 3 avril
soit 7 jours 7 jours plus tard et il
explique que ce jour-là il était au fond
de son jardin en train de chercher son
chat il était tout seuls les enfants
étaient ailleurs à l'école et combien
d'enfant ils ont ensemble ils ont deux
enfants qui ont 12 et 14 ans et elle
avait elle trois enfants d'un premier
mariage et tâché de 54 ans d'accord
et donc il cherche son chat et lorsqu'il
revient l'histoire ne dit pas s'il a
trouvé son chat en tout cas quand il
revient son épouse Karine n'est plus
dans la dans la maison
il ne s'en inquiète pas puisqu'il reçoit
il dit avoir reçu un sms environ un
quart d'heure plus tard où elle lui
explique que elle ne supporte plus
finalement cette vie parce que c'est un
couple lui dit lui explique que c'est un
couple qui était séparé depuis 4 ans et
donc dans ce sms elle se plaint de
de cette de cette vie qui ne lui
convenait pas qu'elle avait le ressenti
le besoin de partir et de voir d'autres
horizons elle parlait du Sud des pays
chacun
les enfants également recevront des
messages des SMS une photo une photo du
Mont-Saint-Michel sur laquelle ne figure
pas
et les jours passent et puis le maire je
crois que c'est le 9 avril le maire du
village de Maché
découvre le téléphone portable enfin un
téléphone portable dans un fossé à
quelques centaines de mètres du domicile
de des époux pial et ce téléphone est
allumé
ce téléphone est allumé il est chargé et
il est dépourvu de sa carte SIM
et à partir de là ça commence à
inquiéter les ça commence à inquiéter
les enquêteurs les gendarmes et ils vont
s'apercevoir au fur et à mesure d'un
certain nombre d'incohérences
oui c'est vrai et d'après le mari Michel
la femme aurait emmené des objets alors
ça c'est un témoignage aussi
c'est toujours lui qui est toujours lui
bien sûr elle serait partie avec 43000
euros une valeur de 43000 euros
un tiers en espèces et les deux tiers en
pièces d'or
alors au départ on s'oriente le Rocket
s'orient sur une disparition volontaire
voilà oui si vous voulez Michel pial
quand il va à la gendarmerie il explique
que le couple n'allait plus enfin que
c'était ça vraiment un groupe mais les
plus au mieux
décidé de partir c'est ce que sont les
les gendarmes leur ils sont le
réceptacle il leur dit enfin ils
entendent Michel pial ils ont pas de
moyens de de comparer de vérifier en
temps réel donc ça c'est le travail qui
vont faire après d'ailleurs on voit le
résultat que ça donne quelques jours
plus tard il y a le portable de Karine
qui va être retrouvé proche d'une aire
de repos oui tout à fait quelques
centaines de mètres du domicile du
couple alors
est-ce que ça peut aider en faveur de la
disparition volontaire ça ou est-ce que
c'est ça peut être une mise en scène ça
pose un problème parce que déjà il met 7
jours pour signaler la disparition de de
son épouse bon on peut comprendre que le
couple allait moyennement bien ou sans
fin était vivait chacun leur leur vie
mais sept jours c'est quand même long et
le téléphone on le retrouve donc encore
six jours plus tard 7 jours plus tard
donc ça veut dire que ce téléphone est
resté 15 jours en gros
dans le village dans un village de 1500
habitants
on l'aurait forcément vu et en vérifiant
ultérieurement les gendarmes
s'aperçoivent que ce téléphone n'a pas
bougé du village il géolocalise dans ce
village depuis le départ de de Karine
alors il a été placé en garde à vue oui
pourquoi alors les gendarmes ont vérifié
bien évidemment tout ce qu'il a raconté
quand il a été entendu quand il devenu
signaler la disparition de Karine et
puis les gendarmes on vérifié
méthodiquement tous les tous les
éléments que fournissaient Michel pial
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il y a des problèmes il y a des gros
problèmes d'abord sur le délai enfin
sept jours je l'ai déjà dit
quand elle part il a donné des versions
différentes à plusieurs personnes un
coup elle est partie en taxi un coup
elle est partie il l'a pas vu et une
autre fois il dit qu'il est monté dans
une voiture et qu'il a couru derrière la
voiture bon la vérité est où personne
pour l'instant n'en sait rien
le plus gros problème qui pointait du
doigt ce sont vraiment les
contradictions se marient comme vous
venez de le dire et et il y a aussi son
profil quoi alors j'ai pas tout à fait
fini avec la conviction mais je peux
vite il y a les SMS on s'aperçoit que
Michel pial dit avoir reçu des messages
de de son épouse et on s'aperçoit en
réalité que le téléphone n'a pas bougé
du village donc
il y a de là imaginer que c'est un tiers
je dis pas que c'est lui mais que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre mais qui ne serait pas
Carine qui aurait utilisé le téléphone
de Karine pour envoyer ces fameux
message
il y a un élément aussi qui était un peu
un peu accablant un peu embêtant pour
lui c'est que le 27 mars lorsque sa
femme disparaît il va à l'école pour
récupérer ses enfants et là on le décrit
salle et transpirant ça veut tout dire
et rien dire mais si c'est vous si c'est
moi ça n'a pas d'importance si c'est le
jour où votre femme disparaît c'est un
petit peu plus gênant maintenant ça peut
peut-être s'expliquer autrement je ne
sais je
il aurait aussi tenté de on dit que son
ex-femme aurait parlé d'un homme
mythomane bord dangereux
oui alors ça ça fait partie un petit peu
de son passé son ex-femme a été entendu
elle dit beaucoup de choses qui sont peu
amènent à son endroit elle dit en gros
qu'effectivement c'était un mythomane
que c'était un escroc d'ailleurs il a 9
condamnations pour escroquerie il faut
ils sachent de faux depuis 1998 et en
2021 très récemment il a été embringué
dans une histoire de folingon d'or de
faux lingot d'or pardon alors lui il
explique ça en disant qu'il s'était fait
arnaquer mais je veux dire ça ça existe
en tout cas il y a cette
tenté d'empoisonner alors ça c'est
l'ex-femme qui le décrit comme un mytho
il se serait fait passer pour un agent
secret
auprès de son épouse inventant des
missions
en France ou sur ou en extérieur et
elle se plaint également un soir il y a
20 ans très exactement
dîner avec ses parents elle est en
compagnie de Michel pial et
il avait fait des une omelette aux
champignons tout le monde a mangé sauf
lui et tout le monde a été malade on
finit à l'hôpital donc elle en déduit
assez légitimement qu'elle a été victime
d'un empoisonnement alors on va recevoir
Adélaïde ce qu'ils vont c'est la sœur de
Karine et c'est vrai que on a vraiment
envie d'avoir son témoignage et de tout
ce que vous nous dites là c'est vrai que
l'affaire est quand même assez curieuse
et il y a des éléments comme c'est
bizarre je sais pas si ce qui est
conduire la vue et que pour l'instant la
présomption d'une instance exactement
vous êtes bien de le préciser vous
faites très bien de le préciser regardez
sur BFM il raconte ce qui s'est passé
et explique il explique qu'elle était
très différente ces derniers temps
regardez ce que Michel a donné des
exercices pour moi c'était pas possible
c'est pour ça que je t'ai pas sonné
qu'elle allait revenir elle avait lâché
plusieurs choses voilà il y avait les
choses étaient moins présentes ce
qu'elle avait en fait été présente mais
sa tête était ailleurs
je me dis que bon c'est pas impossible
c'est plus impossible la preuve c'est
qu'elle est pas là
et qu'elle est pas partie il y a
personne qui l'a forcé parce que j'ai
entendu crier un pied là et puis elle a
pris des affaires qui étaient dans
différents endroits d'aller à la maison
quelqu'un qui la force c'était
impossible de devenir dans la maison en
10 minutes sans que j'entende c'est
impossible donc elle est partie
volontairement oui ça c'est certain par
contre après ce qui se fait passer après
c'est l'inconnu total quoi donc Michel
qui donne des interviews qui donnent des
cadeaux les interviews qui est
actuellement garde à vue donc le mari et
nous sommes avec Adélaïde la sœur de
Karine merci d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup je sais que c'est compliqué
pour vous et je tiens à dire Adélaïde
c'est c'est important de le dire elle
est là ce soir pour bien sûr pour que ça
avance pour que voilà c'est c'est
compliqué pour Adélaïde d'être là mais
c'est important aussi donc merci à vous
merci à vous je sais que c'est compliqué
mais merci d'être là et voilà
vraiment voilà prenez votre temps on
sait que c'est sûrement très compliqué
parce que Karine votre sœur a disparu le
27 mars dernier il y a plus de deux mois
maintenant c'est ça doit être je vous
dis je vous mets à votre place c'est
c'est
un enfer
c'était votre petite sœur ma grande sœur
on a 15 mois d'écart et
vous avez appris la disparition de votre
sœur vous étiez très proche d'elle oui
oui avec des périodes où on s'appelait
plus ou moins on se voyait pas beaucoup
depuis quelques années mais on est des
soeurs
qui c'est beaucoup
depuis le début
vous le dites vous ne croyez pas un
instant qui a pu disparaître
volontairement
[Musique]
je trouvais qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'incohérences et
voilà partir entre le châle la rentrée
des enfants enfin ça me paraît que c'est
complètement fou et puis d'autant plus
que vu que leur situation était
apparemment voilà il séparait même s'il
vivait toujours ensemble je connaissant
ma soeur qui est quelqu'un qui
communique qui est ouverte je vois pas
pourquoi elle aurait pas parlé
à Michel d'un besoin de de partir et
sans dire au revoir à ses enfants
vous avez été inquiète première un truc
qui tourne pas tout de suite à l'instant
je l'ai appris mon sang n'a fait qu'un
tour et
j'étais tout de suite une voilà une
angoisse
alors au coeur de l'enquête il y a le
couple pour l'instant bien sûr il y a
une présomption d'innocence
est actuellement en garde à vue on va
voir ce qu'il va sortir de la garde à
vue
est-ce que le couple elle vous disait
quoi votre sœur très peu de choses sur
la intimité
on parlait vraiment d'autres choses on
prenait des
passions ce que je faisais ce qu'elle
faisait beaucoup des enfants parce que
c'est voilà c'était un sujet pour elle
elle aimait bien comme on se voyait peu
de voilà me parler des enfants de leur
évolution de leur quotidien surtout de
Jules qui a un problème de surdité donc
voilà c'était des conversations plutôt
banales
placé en garde à vue son mari vous
connaissez forcément bien vous vous
entendez bien avec lui c'était quoi sa
personnalité oh quelqu'un de plutôt
avenant communicant sociable
plutôt sympathique voilà avoir comme ça
voilà vous étiez vous entendiez bien
avec lui oui j'ai jamais eu de bagarres
avec lui mais bon depuis des années je
les voyais plus beaucoup aussi et donc
dès le départ vous avez pensé à lui ou
pas un moment quand elle a disparu pas
du tout Oui ah oui tout de suite ah oui
pas tout de suite bien sûr parce que bon
c'est difficile déjà voilà d'imaginer
qu'il ait pu lui faire quelque chose
bien entendu et il y a tellement
d'incohérences qui enfin que j'ai senti
tout de suite donc forcément ben
voilà dans les hypothèses j'ai voilà
j'ai vous l'avez appelé vous l'avez
contacté je l'ai appris le 31
Michel non non il m'a appelé le 10 mai
pour la première fois 43 jours après la
disparition de ma sœur
d'un trait et puis très rapidement il
m'a parlé de ma sœur comme quelqu'un qui
avait démissionné
et qui n'était plus voilà qui qui
n'était plus soutien qui s'occupait plus
de la maison qui était des investi des
leçons pour Jules pour les enfants et
qu'elle entretenait enfin qu'il avait
entendu dire qu'elle aurait des
conversations le soir tard sur des
réseaux avec d'autres hommes
et puis là j'ai écouté tout ce qu'il
avait à me dire et je pars connu ma sœur
ça me c'est pas elle donc c'est ce qui
dit lui bien sûr moi je peux pas
vérifier tout ça mais je le crois pas
enfin vous croyez pas du tout si vous a
dit pas comme ça enfin qu'après qu'elle
est sentie peut-être un mal d'etre enfin
qu'elle est traversée un moment
intérieurement compliqué je je peux le
croire sans problème mais partir comme
ça tout laisser elle était tellement
bienveillante pour sa famille investie
dans son quotidien c'est une femme très
courageuse et elle a toujours menée de
front alors Michel il a beaucoup
témoigner dans les médias auprès de ses
proches ils sont donnés des versions
différentes trajectoires
qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça quand
vous avez vu moi aussi je les ai relevés
il suffit d'écouter de lire par exemple
quand il m'a parlé du jour du 27 du jour
de sa disparition
bon voilà il me dit j'ai apparemment vu
une voiture un taxi un Hubert
bon voilà mais pas plus c'était
compliqué dans le jardin c'est grand
c'est où j'ai cru apercevoir quelque
chose puis ensuite j'ai lu peu de temps
après et il a dit ben oui mais c'est une
voiture qui n'est pas connue stationne
plus de 10 minutes dans le dans le
lieu-dit Les tout le monde note la
plaque tout le monde le voit donc je lui
dis bon
voilà le téléphone aussi quand je lui ai
parlé de ce que je lui ai posé des
questions le soir où je l'ai eu donc ce
10 MAI et je vais parler du téléphone on
venait juste de le retrouver la veille
et je lui dis mais c'est fou je sais pas
ça choque pas le téléphone il me dit oh
elle a dû installer un VPN sur son
téléphone alors là j'ai eu un choc parce
que
montrent que le mari de votre sœur
notamment vous parlez du téléphone
exercer une emprise sur elle sur les
enfants
contrôlaient les téléphones est-ce que
vous aviez eu vent de ça est-ce qu'elle
vous en avez parlé est-ce que ça vous
étonne quand on dit ça on se marie que
vous connaissez non pas plus que ça non
ça m'étonne pas plus que ça et ma soeur
pendant des années elle avait pas de
téléphone ils en avaient qu'un en commun
et donc quand j'appelais ma soeur j'ai
voilà il était enregistré à Michel et
Karine et donc c'est toujours Michel qui
décrochait donc bon évidemment il
passait à ma soeur on se disait bonjour
et ensuite elle en a eu un il y a
quelques années de téléphone et elle
avait beaucoup de mal à le charger à
voilà c'était pour elle ça la gonflé un
peu le téléphone donc c'est pas
quelqu'un mais donc je passe voilà quand
je parlais avec ma sœur j'ai toujours
Michel qui était là donc voilà il y
avait jamais l'un sans l'autre
on sent tous les choses voilà alors
présomption d'innocence certaine
aujourd'hui il est juste placé en garde
à vue je tiens à le dire le redis encore
ce soir parce qu'il est 21h08 on en
direct c'est important de le dire oui
vous quand vous l'avez eu au téléphone
est-ce que vous avez dit à vos proches
non je pense je le sens bien je pense
qu'il y avait été où est-ce que vous
l'avez dit il me semble bizarre à mes
proches oui
quand j'en ai parlé avec des amis
proches
oui tous les gens et il me disaient
effectivement bon Michel c'est flou quoi
il y a quelque chose autour de lui qui
est difficilement palpable et
oui les gens tous très inquiets quoi
Karine vous êtes en contact avec
chez les Karine oui avec les deux aînés
Antoine Thomas et Antoine
c'est normal
parce que on se met tous à leur place et
on se dit si ça nous arrivait une
disparition il y a c'est horrible
vraiment on attend tous les jours on se
dit il va se passer un truc il va on a
ce qu'on a encore espoir et un autre
côté plus le temps passe et puis nous on
se dit l'espoir ça me nuise et quand
vous imaginez ça arrive à votre mère
donc je pense très très fort à eux ce
soir et d'autant plus vous rendez compte
si en plus dans le même temps votre papa
est en garde à vue là c'est quand même
un moment quand même très très difficile
en plus c'est c'est un truc de fou ouais
complètement et Thomas c'est Thomas qui
me l'a appris le 31 mars il venait de la
prendre juste quelques minutes
auparavant par son plus jeune frère
Antoine et il était tout de suite
immédiatement bouleversée très inquiet
enfin voilà et maman a disparu elle se
serait d'après Michel
parti en pleine après-midi en quelques
minutes avec quelques affaires et là bon
moi j'ai c'est ça fait qu'un tour quoi
sur Michel les enfants
bon ils le connaissent pas énormément
c'est un premier mariage c'est ça faut
le dire voilà aussi
les enfants de du premier mariage de ma
sœur et ensuite ensemble ils ont eu
trois enfants évanouissent qui a 20 ans
et que vous avez monté au téléphone je
l'ai moins ôté les enfants
j'espère la voir au téléphone bien sûr
à tous les 5 enfants parce que c'est
vrai qu'ils ont trois enfants ensemble
et eux c'est encore si c'est encore pire
et ils vous ont ils vous ont ils vous
ont rien dit sur Michel il s'entendez
bien avec lui mal peut qu'il voyait oui
ils ont vécu une période les deux
enfants aînés quand ils sont rentrés de
l'île de la Réunion ils ont vécu une
période ils sont passés par par la
Malnoue donc ils ont vécu un peu en
Vendée avec Karine et Michel donc bon
voilà ils ont appris à le connaître mais
c'est vrai qu'il me rapportait pas des
événements une racontait pas
spécialement ce qui se passait là-bas le
temps le temps ils ont vécu aujourd'hui
vous êtes dans
dans quelle disposition j'ai envie de ce
que vous avez encore un infime espoir ou
est-ce que vous vous dites on va prendre
le pire dans les moments dans les heures
les les jours à venir il y a une garde à
vue actuellement voilà est-ce que vous
vous dites
que vous vous dites on va on va on va
savoir la vérité la vérité ou bien ma
sœur va réapparaître vous dites quoi ce
serait l'idéal qu'elle rase paraître
bien sûr qu'elle est j'en garde un petit
espoir j'ai besoin de ça pour faire face
qui est aussi terrible c'est ça
aussi m'attendre à quelque chose
d'épouvantable mais je voilà j'ai besoin
de garder cet espoir aujourd'hui vous
avez envie que voilà de savoir la vérité
aussi j'en ai besoin je peux pas c'est
pas possible si non dans ces cas ça
toute la journée
[Musique]
c'est la chape quoi ce bouton dessus et
voilà cette plaqué au sol et puis
c'est difficile
aujourd'hui
je m'inquiète beaucoup j'ai peur
vous avez peur d'avoir je suis sûr que
dès que votre téléphone sonne dès que
vous dites on va on va m'annoncer ou
vous êtes contente parce qu'on va vous
annoncer une bonne nouvelle mais on vous
dites on va m'annoncer peut-être le pire
mais bon j'ai besoin de la vérité comme
toute la famille
c'est nécessaire pour
pour continuer
aujourd'hui
Michel
la garde à vue on va savoir très vite
demain matin demain matin voilà ce qui
en sort et si elle est prolongée les
gens
peuvent encore la prolonger encore une
fois
ils ont fait les premières 24 heures le
parquet pour l'instant rien n'en est
ressorti de ce que vous savez à ma
connaissance sinon il participe aux
auditions il n'a pas fait droit à son il
n'a pas fait usage de son droit au
silence
mais a priori il reste campé sur ses
positions il donne sa ces versions et
c'est vrai qu'il y a plein
d'incohérences alors la garde à vue
c'est aussi fait pour ça c'est pour
qu'il s'explique peut-être on dira
parfaitement blanchi demain matin c'est
tout à fait possible en même temps c'est
vrai qu'il y a des choses qui vont pas
je pense un petit détail qui il dit tout
le monde enfin aujourd'hui il dit à tout
le monde qu'ils étaient séparés depuis 4
ans donc vous vous êtes la sœur vous
n'étiez pas au courant et une de leur
fil dit avoir apporté le son petit
déjeuner dit avoir apporté le petit
déjeuner à ses parents ils étaient
ensemble dans la même chambre et dans le
même lit
voilà c'est tout simple
alors comme il a une tendance
mythomaniaque peut-être qu'il se noie
dans ses mensonges et qu'il n'est pour
rien dans cette histoire c'est c'est
aussi une possibilité j'en sais rien je
suis pas j'ai pas de boule de cristal
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des
incohérences c'est que on les a à peu
près toutes relevés écoutez en espérant
vraiment que on va avoir des bonnes
nouvelles on est voilà il y a toujours
un espoir et on espère qu'on va avoir
des bonnes nouvelles pour vous pour la
famille pour les enfants